i am here today
to show the united kingdom's steadfast
support for ukraine
i'm very impressed that despite
the russian aggression towards ukraine
that life here in kiev
goes on
and i am impressed by the level of
stoicism
both from the ukrainian people
and the ukrainian government
we admire your fortitude in the face of
russian aggression
and we stand with you in defense of your
right to determine your own future
we're very proud as a united kingdom to
be at the forefront of support for
ukraine
we've provided defensive weapons and
we've trained 22 000 members of the
ukrainian army and when the prime
minister visited kiev earlier this month
he announced we're providing 88 million
to support ukraine's democracy and
energy independence
today
i can announce the next component of our
support
increasing our funding for these
projects to a value of 100 million
pounds
i'm also proud together with dimitro to
be launching our new trilateral
partnership with poland and ukraine
we will intensify work on defence and
security
sanctions
energy security encountering
disinformation
and this demonstrates the united kingdom
is willing and ready to stand shoulder
to shoulder with allies across eastern
and central europe
russia must think again
despite their claims
russia's military buildup shows no signs
of slowing
there is currently no evidence that
their forces are withdrawing
and we need russia to step back from the
brink
they must take the path of diplomacy
last week
i delivered a strong message to sergey
lavrov in moscow
i told him directly
that russia must respect ukraine's
sovereignty and engage in meaningful
talks
if do they if they do not choose the
path
that we have laid out
i made it clear the price that russia
would pay
we are ready with our allies to impose
severe costs on russia
there would be severe economic costs
through an unprecedented package of
coordinated sanctions
the united states have been clear
that nordstrom 2 would not go ahead
and russia would risk creating a
prolonged and drawn-out war with a
terrible toll
which would be borne by the russian
people
russia would confirm its status
as an international pariah instead
i urge the kremlin once again to
de-escalate and to choose diplomacy
in the revolution of dignity the
ukrainian people are clear about the
future they want
they chose freedom
and we will show the free world is
prepared to stand up and support you
in that choice
together we can turn the tide on russian
aggression
and we can build a more secure future
for all of us right across europe thank
you
thank you very much um foreign secretary
you've warned that russia could draw out
this crisis with ukraine for months yet
today we've seen a spike in violence in
the east and concerns about the
potential for escalation in your opinion
do you think it's more likely that there
is going to be an imminent offensive by
russia or that we're facing a prolonged
stalemate
well there is of course
a significant chance that there could be
offensive action by russia
if not
why are there a hundred thousand troops
on the border with ukraine
but russia can still take the path of
diplomacy
they can de-escalate they can move their
troops away from the border
and i believe that's in the interests of
european security
but it's also in russia's interests